[Music]
hi my name is Eric I'm a software
engineer at Twitter so when I was
thinking about what I wanted to talk
about I wanted to think about what was
something new that related to my
experience at Twitter and what's
something that's not being talked about
typically at tech conferences and I kind
of thought well you know Twitter's goal
is to reach every person on this planet
and the thing is we can't do that
effectively if we don't consider our
users language their culture and in the
environment they live in
so this talk we're gonna go over like
how to localize your app and make the
app feel native to your users and so you
can grow your app from your local
audience to a international audience
these are some of the products I've
worked on I worked on digits which is
now part of firebase off and you know we
serve two hundred and seventeen
countries and we supported 34 different
languages I also worked on Twitter Ken
this allowed developers to embed tweets
into their apps so this is how we kind
of grow the reach of Twitter doc beyond
just our users inside the app and then
I'm currently working on the Twitter for
Android platform and I'm working on
emerging market performance so as we
improve performance or top-line metrics
will improve and I'll talk a little bit
about that on my slide - all right so
the first topic is like localization so
like I said you want your app to feel
native to the users users and so when we
talk about locales generally there's
like two components to a locale there's
the language
there's geography so and this is because
for example oh that's my yeah so like
Spanish speaks poking in Mexico is it
the same as Spanish spoken in Spain and
there's also some cultural differences
between Spain and Spanish and how we
display dates and times and number
formats so that's why there's these two
components to a locale so this ayah this
is mostly focused on Android and how to
do it but these same things pretty much
apply web Android and iOS
so okay you want to get started you've
decided you want to grow the reach of
your market so what what's kind of the
first step the first one is you want to
like identify your market opportunity so
you want to go ahead and look like
what's the relative wealth of the region
you want to target what is the
penetration of smartphones and what's
the population size you know you want to
make sure if you're going to go through
all this effort you get the biggest bang
for your buck the other thing is want to
consider your competitive landscape if
you have a music streaming app and you
want to come to the United States you
can have a lot of competition you know
there's Spotify there's title there's
Pandora
there's Amazon music there's Google
music so maybe the United States isn't
the best place to start and then also
just the financial and regulatory
factors of the region you want to
operate like click-through rates of
India are far lower than let's say in
the United States so you want me to take
these financial considerations into play
and the kind of the regulatory regimes
of each country so here's an example in
the United States we have 37 millions
native Spanish speakers so these are
people according to the Census Bureau
that's each Spanish at home every day
and for context like the United States
population is about 320 million so about
10% of the population and 2.8 million
Chinese speakers so this is mainly
Mandarin and Cantonese and these groups
in the United States control two point
one trillion dollars in household
spending so this is actually a big
opportunity in the United States for
example to just take your app and
localize it in the Spanish and here
you're reaching these users who and
you're making the app feel native to
them in their own language so like how
do you get started so very big I mean
these are the basic steps to get you
started and get your app ready for it
translation I'm not gonna really go over
like how to select a translating company
or where you can go but basically you go
find these services online they usually
charge something like eight cents to 18
cents per word translation and you know
it goes from just native speakers
translating professional translators and
you have professional translators and
then they'll have someone double-check
to work and the goal here is once we
have a vendor we want to have high
quality translations we want a quick
turnaround and we don't want a lot of
back-and-forth you know we want to avoid
I always hate it when I get a juror
ticket from my translation team and
saying hey we don't understand what's
going on here or we need more context
and so that takes back-and-forth and
then it delays my future shipping
because I haven't translated everything
I need so like how do we go about doing
this so you've probably all seen these
warnings in Android studio they've been
in since like Android studio to just
make sure any string literals you have
you can just convert them into string
resources there's like a quick-fix
tooltip you just click extract resources
you get this little dialogue you just
decide where you want your default value
set and that's it you should have
something like this everything should be
in a string resource so yeah this is
your file this is what's going to be
sent to the translation Center and the
goal here is to get something back
that's translated and it's high-quality
and hopefully you haven't done too much
back and forth so what can we do so how
can we go about doing this so you want
to provide like context-free declared
strings you want to think so in this
case my app is called demonstration and
demonstration it in English is what's a
homonym and so these words that are
spelled the same and they sound the same
but they have different meaning and so
when they go translated into other
languages it might not be clear which
meaning you mean so in these comments
section provide that context to your
translators so in this case my app is
demonstrating how to translate things so
this is a practical and you know
explanation of how something works so
make sure you include that inside of
your description and you know other
languages have similar things there's
like hetero gnomes and there's also
homier grass so these are like words are
spelt the same but are but sound
different like a bow and arrow or the
power of a boat also include like where
are these strings gonna be kept and so
that gives in context to the translator
you know do they need to keep the string
shorter do they need do they have more
room to work with things you know if
they need to if it's a
resource-constrained space maybe they
can choose a different synonym for the
word in that shorter and so some of
these things you know like buttons
they're usually more space constrained
so they know to be really short with
their the language like app name it's
limited to 30 characters so make sure
your translators know
limits so that they can keep to them and
then of course mark the things that you
shouldn't be translated you don't want
to waste time and money having things
that are translated that shouldn't be so
brand names typically aren't translated
so Twitter isn't gonna be translated
into Chinese it's not gonna be
translated in Spanish I'm searching
proper names placeholders and especial
Unicode characters obviously URLs you
don't want you URL is going to 404 x'
and then code and also here you can see
this is the placeholder syntax so this
is a XML localization interchange file
format and you can have placeholders so
when you preview the string inside your
layout preview it'll show true as a
default so that's a fun little trick so
okay you've gone through you've
translated everything but now what about
dates currency and numbers these are
things that generally don't vary by
language but they vary by the region
you're located in and so Android Android
iOS and a lot of back-end systems they
provide a lot of these tools and they're
all backed by the IBM ICU library it's
the international components for Unicode
it's basically C C++ library and it has
like a Java wrapper and it supports a
lot of internationalization and
localization functions for you and
showing the correct time and date and
format really helps you users recognize
what's going on you know for example I
landed here I got off the airplane I
like I really needed a coffee and I
looked at the price it said ten thousand
and I was thinking wait a minute I can't
be right and then I realized wait they
just used to come as a decimal place
holder here we're in the United States
to use the period but you know as a US
user I was initially confused it took a
while for me to think about that in
cross
so one of the things like I enjoy and
they have a fun little feature is called
best get best date time pattern
unfortunately it's only available on
jellybean mr2 plus and what this does is
you can use these unicode date patterns
you know the end them for the two-digit
month day in here and what happens is
the order and that the separators for
the dates are irrelevant so you give it
what you want and then it'll return the
correct format for you so here I can
give it month day year and for you for
Ukraine and orderly day month year with
the periods in between and so like here
are some easy examples in the United
States we do month/day/year France day
month year with the slash you know Japan
starts with the year and then here in
the Ukraine so that should look familiar
to all the Ukrainian developers I hope
also like I mentioned there's also
helpers for decimal points too so in the
u.s. we use the period as a decimal
point and we used to come as a thousand
separator so like when I saw a number
that's why it was like initial confusion
for me how's a US user and so by
displaying these numbers correctly
you know your users will feel like this
is a native experience to them and same
thing with currency there's currency
helpers so don't make sure that the
currency symbols are located in the
correct place
one thing I learned with digits is that
phone numbers are actually really hard
it's a very hard problem to solve and
there's a lot there's actually one
really good library there it's like live
phone number and Android uses this phone
live phone number from Google to provide
you some formatting features and Android
so what you can do is you can store all
your phone numbers in one common format
so there's like an itu standard e.164
and this kind of describes how you can
format international numbers what
happens is you've got users local users
I want to see a number in their national
format is what it's called and so you
can give it the string that you save
maybe in your database and then when you
display the string to the users you know
it'll be formatted in a way that they
expect to see you so like the same again
US France Ukraine and the UK also you
notice I used a bunch of these constants
originally I hadn't used some constants
and I thought UK was the country code
but it's really GP so use some of these
constants and they'll be helpful
another issue like I ran into with
imagination digits is we want to display
a whole list of countries so you wanted
to select your country code and we had a
list of countries but when we
internationalized things strings weren't
sorting in the correct order I you know
as a us-based developer this will work
right because they're all ASCII
characters but what happens is when you
start to introduce Unicode characters or
you look at other languages like the NEA
and an NEA in Spanish you want to make
sure they're sorted in the correct order
and also some languages like Spanish
also have the double el check has like
the CH so these are called by grass so
there's a lot of these other characters
that you want to make sure things are
sorted correctly and if you're sorting
things by the code point it won't work
so don't do this for sorting and what
you want to do is use this collator
feature so this is also provided by the
ICU library and here what we're going to
do is excuse me we want to look we're
gonna set a strange and what happens is
we set primary and so it's gonna sort
based on primary differences so capital
A and lowercase a are actually secondary
differences so they'll sort in the same
order and also like in Spanish with the
double el Spanish is actually adapted to
like technology standards so now the
double L is actually treated as just two
individual ELLs in sorting and so it'll
help you don't provide these functions
to sort everything for you so now you
know when you go to my drop-down list
and we have the localize list of
countries I go ahead and I use this
collator and the sort things and now
everything's sorted based on the correct
locale
so other considerations when localizing
things is machine the machine
interactions generally you want to keep
you don't want to use the default locale
for machine to machine transactions you
want to specify the locale that you're
using like if the date is day is 17 but
I in the US you know the parsing of that
thing's gonna fail because there's no 17
month of the year so making sure that
you the locale matches the locality or
API and then translate that into the
future you need um units of measure or
another thing in the United States we
use the imperial system we're only one
of three countries that do that so
that's pretty easy to solve and then
other domains some specific domains have
like conventions that don't match the
locale so if you're doing like a
scientific application generally it's
used in metric right so no matter if
you're in the United States or Europe or
the rest of the world you would still
continue to use metric system and in
Android 24 plus now they have some new
API is provided by ICU just to make you
aware them so if you're packaging the
ICU library it's pretty big so now it's
included as part of Android so you can
create like an apk split 24 plus you can
use the built in ICU libraries 24 and
below you could just you have to package
your own but this way your apk would be
smaller
so RTL so not all users read from left
to right some users also go right to
left and so these common languages
Arabic Hebrew Russian and are due are
the biggest languages so here's an
example there's a hundred and sixty
million Arabic speaking users on the
internet and there's 80% phone shipped
in the Middle East support Android and
but there's only eight point eight
percent of web content is in Arabic so
if you're like an let's say the Arabic
Spotify you have this huge audience you
can reach now if you have this content
in the Arabic language and so like how
would you go about you know localizing
your app for these languages so a little
history Android for o was localized in
Arabic and it also include an Arabic
grieshaber so you might ask what's a
reshape er
Arabic is kind of like a cursive
language and so with that Ari Shaffir up
top you see all the characters or it's
isolated form and each characters
rendered the same regardless of its
surroundings and so as an Arabic reader
you know it's gonna be slowing that you
down it's kind of like cursive you know
and if I wrote cursive on a space
everything out you would be confused and
you would have a your your comprehension
of what you're reading would take a
longer time so with the reshape er what
happens it reshapes the characters
according to the surrounding characters
for you and so that'll be more natural
for your Arabic speaking users in
Android 4.1 they have a bi-directional
text support for technics view so what
happens is the text viewer automatically
detect the language and the side whether
to display things left there right but
it wasn't very smart it would just look
at the first character say it's an RTL
and shiftings right to left or left to
right in 4.2 you got layout mirroring
and some better font
and then 4.3 we being improved by
directional support so now they include
some heuristics so if you have a mixed
content like Arabic and English it'll go
through you can apply various heuristics
and oversee whether to display your
content right - laughter up left to
right so here's an example of
bi-directional support so here I have
English or fake English whatever that is
and then it's better the way everything
out left to right and then I just switch
my device or I switch to text to Arabic
it detected this it was Arabic and it
was right to left language no work he
didn't have to do anything
RTL Ameri so what happens is you want
your right-to-left users to experience
the app the same way you do so as you
scan the app you see my profile then you
see like my username and then you see
the text as you go across so you want
your users to have that same experience
in the right to left so what you can do
is you you have to go to your manifest
and then saved that your app supports
RTL so you have to go ahead and just
enable RTL support and then what we can
do is go into find you see these are you
know layout to the left of well instead
of left you could do end of and what
happens is in a left-to-right
the start is the left side of the screen
and the end is the right side of the
screen but when you're an RTL mode the
start is at the right side of the screen
and your end is at the left side of the
screen so you can define these
parameters and then when you switch it
everything will be laid out correctly
the padding should be correct and if
you're targeting 17-plus you can just
get rid of these left to right things
altogether and there's actually lint
warnings and the tools that I'll kind of
tell you this so there you go you switch
it to your RTL language and now
everything's laid out and your right to
left late language speakers experience
the app the same
way as you left-to-right language
speakers one thing I found out is that
viewpager
does not support right-to-left languages
so it doesn't automatically so you might
be scrolling to the right but you're you
know right to left language are gonna
want to scroll to the right so this is a
long-standing request by the community
but there's a lot of other developers
that have created solutions for you so
one of these is RTL pick new pager by
duolingo and then also there's drawable
mirroring in some cases you might want
to just flip the image to mirror it I've
never had it use for that and then but
the one useful feature I find is that
the Force RTL option so you can go into
settings force RTL and it'll take
whatever default locale you're on
already but just layout everything right
to left and that helps you find bugs and
it's really useful because before I'd
have to switch my phone to Arabic and
then I couldn't find the setting to get
back to English so that was a little
troublesome so I had an opportunity to
talk with some developers in the Middle
East in India and one of the things they
told me was you know for sorry for the
Arabic language like you need to make
the font bigger and I was like well I
wonder if Google's thought about this
they must have so I went to the material
of guidelines and read through them and
they basically us make the strip's into
three different categories so there's
like the English like ones which are
Latin Greek and Cyrillic you know the
dense ones like Chinese and then the
tall ones which are some of these Middle
Eastern languages and the guides
basically said hey for these other four
dense and tall
you should make these characters bigger
to make them more readable so you know
kind of what I'm hearing from developers
and users you know Google's already
incorporated into some of these
guidelines so these material guidelines
it will be very helpful in making sure
that your users and everything's
readable laid out
so the other thing is testing how do you
you know what are some of the things you
want to look for when testing your
localization so you know you want to
have a test environment set up you can
look for common issues and then you know
a twitter we're a pretty large company
and we hire people from all over the
world we have people that speak
ukrainian you know we have people that
speak russian we have people that speak
english we have people that speak
spanish so you know these are people
that can help give you feedback on your
app and how it feels so here's a list of
some common issues i mean worst case you
have to crash because maybe you have a
placeholder out of order or something
but a lot of these things a lot of the
obvious things are caught by the winter
for you but you know you can go through
the app manually you can see that things
are sorted correctly look for
untranslated text you know look for poor
line wrapping and stuff for those rtl
languages you know you can go to the
settings screen and force the RTL layout
and then look at it you know is it
basically a mirror of you left to right
you know is the padding correct or are
the elements where you expect them to be
but I found that to be kind of slow
right I hated switching between settings
and my app and back and forth so one of
the things is on Twitter kick I had a
bunch of timelines I used for testing
and it was just a little simple test app
I display different timelines and so
what I did is I just created a
right-to-left timeline and what I can do
is I can on resume when I started that
activity I just set the locale to Arabic
or I set the language to Arabic and then
on pause I just set the read default
back so here just one click in my test
app I can click I could see that
everything was being displayed quickly
and then continue on just going around
playing with my app so I found that
really useful in speeding things up
I had a video here so this is basically
Dubai Airport Twitter feed the other one
tool I found was from Fastlane this was
developed by fabric and one thing is
screen grabs so he can generalized
localize screenshots of your Android app
so here's an example you set up a simple
script you tell it what locales you want
and then it'll run through and take
screenshots for you and so you can go
through all your screens and then you
can quickly visually look at your
screenshots and say hey this is correct
or my designer always says hey Eric can
you send these screenshots and so you
know I can just run one script take all
these screenshots ship it off and it's
very easy and then supply also in
thinking about localization think about
you know the Play Store and those assets
in there you want those to be localized
so when the user comes to your Play
Store you know they see something and it
looks familiar to them and they go hey I
want to download that so I found these
tools pretty useful so another common
theme when you're looking to grow your
app on beyond these like Western markets
is handling payments so an example is
like the Middle East there's only two
percent of users are people in the
Middle East actually have credit cards
in the United States we all have credit
cards I finally got six credit cards in
my wallet right now 82 percent of them
are unbanked
so they just live day to day with cash I
probably have three or four bank
accounts and then the other thing is
like things like PayPal PayPal you know
is available everywhere but they only
have about a five percent market share
in the Middle East if you want to rely
on them for payments
so like I said PayPal it's available in
all country but there's limited
penetration and generally you need to
have a credit card or a bank account to
take money to pay and then strike which
is very popular is it even available in
the Middle East so what are some
solutions here so some solutions like
carrier billing yeah in this case you
know let's say you want to donate to
something or whatever and you do that
SMS shortcode what happens is it'll
attach of charge to your bill and what
happens generally a carrier charges of
processing fee but these are usually
only for digital goods these are things
that you can just kind of like take the
back if they don't pay their phone bill
it's generally not used for physical
goods although this is becoming a thing
prepaid cards are actually very popular
in North Africa and the Middle East
these are or just young kids without
credit cards you can just go into the
store you know buy like a gift card and
you can keep loading money on that you
just bring currency and it gets at and
usually just a fee associated with like
adding value to the card or processing
the payment I was gonna go back some
other things is like uber in India they
accept cash air B&B if you want to go
book an air B&B in Cuba what they do is
they take your credit card process it
and then they have a courier in Cuba
that'll take the currency and deliver it
to the host so there's a lot of other
solutions some other options are TK me
which is carried a direct billing
provider they're big in the Middle East
and North Africa you know charged things
to the doorbell another thing is like
cash you these are just like I said
three pay cards and you can see Skype
like I said it's popular games and and
boy providers so Skype takes some of
these cards
the final thing is performance
performance matters especially when
you're looking at emerging markets when
you're looking at places like Brazil
Mexico the Philippines and India and
what happens is if when you pay
attention to performance Twitter and a
lot of other companies have found out
like if you increase the performance of
your app you will increase the bottom
line metrics you will sell more products
you will have more engagement people who
are view more tweets or Instagram posts
so this is why performance matters so
much so one thing let's look at India
here India there's about 300 million
wireless subscribers but only 1 million
of them actually have access to 4G
networks so the majority of your users
are either on 3G or 2g networks and even
the LTE even the 4G in 3G networks there
are slower than in most of the Western
countries and they have a lot more
errors right now error rate has higher
in these countries so one thing it
Twitter did is we endeavor to improve
our how we load images because images
would be slow and they wouldn't load and
if you don't see an image or nothing
shows up your user doesn't have an
opportunity to engage with that content
you know they're not gonna like it
they're not gonna click on the tweet and
look at other tweets and so by improving
image loading we believe that we could
increase our top-line metrics which is
you know how often are people engaging
with our tweets so the first thing we
looked at we looked at two technologies
and the first one was web P this is
developed by Google it's built into
Android so you had native support and
you know one thing we found is a 28%
reduction in size compared to PNG s and
it also support its transparency
and we also look at progressive jpg so
progressive jpg takes multiple scans of
your image and loads it progressively so
what we found is like the first scan was
only 10k so it would quickly load that
first image it maybe fuzzy but at least
the users see something that they might
be able to engage with and then over
time it'll load the higher res image so
what happens is the image is compressed
in multiple passes like I said they only
fit the downsides as there's no
transparency support so what we did is
we did transparency detection on the
image so we looked to say does it have
an alpha Channel and then we look even
if it had an alpha Channel we check to
make every pixel and see if every pixel
had an alpha Channel and if there was no
alpha Channel defined we were just
making a progressive jpg otherwise we
leave things as a PNG and the other
thing was there is no native support on
Android and one of the useful things we
found was this fresco library it's an
image loading library from Facebook
you know supported progressive jpgs out
of the gap box and the things that had
no no noticeable feature gaps like in
supported all the things you wanted from
a low image loader so I had caching and
progress bars and scaling and resizing
so it supported everything we needed so
we used fresco as part of our experiment
and the results were really good so what
we decide we ended up going with
progressive jpg when you use Twitter
today that's what you're loading we
found that images were 25% smaller when
compared to PNG s or the JPEGs we saw a
90 percent decrease in p50 load times so
the image loaded faster we saw 74
percent decrease in here errors and most
importantly we saw an increased
engagement especially in the emerging
markets we wanted so it improved their
top-line metrics by just improving how
we load images
and the other thing we do at Twitter is
you know you want to generate that user
empathy we want to feel like what it's
like to actually operate in these 2g
networks and what happens is we have to
g/day occasionally so we throttle all
the accounts employees Twitter accounts
it's on iOS an engine only and so we see
how long things take to load and so you
know we're obviously motivated to fix
things and we also do like cost
notifications so what happens is as you
go through and you're scrolling each day
it'll say hey that same amount of data
you use on your unlimited plan here it
would have cost you $5 in Mexico you
know that's a lot of money so that kind
of gives you a feel for like how much
data were using that's it thank you I
hope you learned something
[Applause]
[Music]